وسط جنوده يظهر البرهان يقول مجلس السياده
السوداني ان رئيسه قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان تجول في محيط القياده العامه
للجيش يحمل البرهان سلاحه في اول ظهور
ميداني له منذ اندلاع الازمه قبل شهر
وايام وفق مقاطع الفيديو فان البرهان ظهر
في مركز القوات البريه بالعاصمه هنا تجري
العمليات العسكريه الرئيسيه لكلا الطرفين
غير بعيد يعلن الجيش السوداني احباظ هجمات
لما سماها ميليشيا الدعم السريع من ثلاثه
اتجاهات مختلفه
تهدف هذه الهجمات وفق الجيش الى زعزعه
الاستقرار في القاعده الجويه العسكريه
بمنطقه وادي سيدنا في ام درمان بالاضافه
الى استهداف الدعم السريع لقياده القطاع
الاوسط للقوات الجويه وفرع الرياضه
العسكريه وسط الخرطوم يقول الجيش انه
استعاد السيطره على هذه المناطق بعد
انسحابه منها لساعات يوم امس
في المقابل تقول قوات الدعم السريع انما
وصفتها بقوه الانقلابيين وفولو النظام
البائد حاولت مباغته ارتكازات قواتها في
منطقه شمال الخرطوم بحري بثت قوات الدعم
مقطع فيديو قالت انه يظهر سيطرتها على
قياده قوات الدفاع الجوي في الخرطوم
الليله الماضيه عقب معارك مع الجيش
السوداني ذلك المكان الذي اكد الجيش
استعاده السيطره عليه بعد الانسحاب لساعات
سياسيا لا تزال جده السعوديه مسرح محادثات
لم توقف اطلاق النار على الارض السودانيه
يقول مصدر دبلوماسي سوداني مطلع للجزيره
ان المفاوضات بوساطه امريكيه سعوديه لا
تزال متواصله بشكل غير رسمي انسانيا اعلنت
الامم المتحده انها بحاجه الى مليارين
وخمسمائه وستين مليون دولار في اطار خطتها
للاستجابه الانسانيه في السودان يشير
مسؤول الامم المتحده الى ان 220 الف شخص
اصبحوا لاجئين في مصر وتشاد وجنوب السودان
جراء الاقتتال المستمر في السودان وهو
يدخل شهره الس